be good yeah they don't yeah so when
you're asking that there's Jewish people
here as if they believe in three gold
they believe in one God but there's been
a lot of Jewish people that came into
Christianity the first Christians were
Jews yeah how many how many could they
believe one God not three
nobody that's Christian believes in
three Gods no no no no again again you
took him from your own domination your
own sects of Christianity but the point
here is Islamic teaching when I say a
simple it makes sense clear cut everyone
can understand it I understand that's
why you know Christianity and I
mentioned that you remember when you can
see me Christianity is dying and a lot
of Christian Youth are living
Christianity either by accepting Islam
or become an atheist
S
no no no no no wait come on man I'll ask
be honest man let us go to the mosque on
Friday and go to churches on Sunday
churches are empty on Sunday come on
Friday when you go to the mosque the
Imam always asking can you donate more
money because we need more space
Christian when you go to Christian
churches they always ask for money for
the priest himself to buy nice clothes
not for the church
maybe here in London but that's not even
America America is known no the priest
was named the Indian guy traveling
everywhere in his own plane
he is a Christian man there's only
Christians like that somebody that's
level is Christian
anyway you know
they gave it to me yeah God gave it to
me yeah
you can't judge a religion or a faith
based on the people
you can't you have to no Jesus said that
Jesus said by their fruits you will know
them that's not my statement so we can
judge when you see the Muslims when he
got the mosque Muslim you know there's a
Christian guy he said to me is my
neighbor he said you know what I like
about Islam you can see the Muslims they
love The Illusion they discipline
no no Christian that you pray one day
Sunday it's empty
name me one Christian country that you
know
yeah
what do you mean by that is there any
Christian country to begin with anyway
yeah
[Music]
Christian countries before
they were Christians
yeah they're working shoes I mean like
historically no they were Christians
they left it America they allowed
Christianity you know I mean you have
people live in Islam as well no I'm not
saying people don't leave Islam as a
whole Christianity is dying is that
we're not in Britain there's a
statistics which has happened every 10
years it's a poll yeah the Christianity
is declining Islam is increasing and
bear in mind there is a huge war against
Islam by the media if the world that has
been waged and gets Islam by the media
whose wage against Christianity
Christianity will disappear but yet even
though there's a usual Angus Islam yet
the fastest Guru in the relation on the
face of the earth is Islam who is doing
the job sorry who's doing the job let me
finish my point anyway who's doing the
job Allah mentioned that in the Quran
1400 years ago that Allah will make
Islam spread out and overpower other
religions even if a disbelievers hate it
and we can observe that with our own
eyes we say what Allah Allah is the
greatest no America operating our
country Allah is the greatest
have you been to America no I've never
been to United States
we should go because like I feel like
your lens is like just stuck in what you
see here in London but you're
I'm not talking down but just because
what you see here doesn't mean what's
going on in the rest of the world and
what you see on the media like the media
portrays a certain perspective of course
and of course you have the the preachers
that pop on private jets and The Jewels
things and stuff but that's not your
normal future and if God knows the
attention of their heart what they're
doing is wrong they're going to be
punished for it eventually but what I'm
saying is like in America or other
people I know like you'll see Muslims
going to the mission praying but then
going out drinking you know committing
in the uh you know doing all types of
stuff but like they're like you said
like your neighbor said oh they go to
the Masjid they pray five times a day
but they're living doing your life
outside of the mission so like that just
because they're doing all that and
they're putting this outer display to
the people doesn't mean that they're I
never said they're perfect you see it's
just one point I've been to a couple of
countries in the world and just cite two
more examples I'm not sure if you know
but let me reach this point about after
I never said they're perfect you see why
you just did you said that some Muslims
go to the mosque and commit mistakes
therefore I'm not talking about that I'm
talking about I didn't say
no don't record him he doesn't want to
be recorded yeah yeah
don't worry even though it's very hard
to be here and not recorded
because you're gonna be a camera
everywhere anyway but I'm trying to tell
them you know I never said they're
perfect you understand I never said that
what shows you they love God but
sometimes they feel weak so they commit
sins and there's no connection between
the two you understand that because
remember when the Jewish people came to
Jesus and they told him about he was
doing something on Sabbath Jesus rebuked
them because themselves there was
something greater than that you
understand so the point here is when you
see the Muslims even though we have some
we're not perfect human beings but we
love our religion we pray we we see the
fruits in the stand however when it
comes to Christianity that's why I said
to you name me a Christian country
Christianity the Europeans have less
Christianity as you know you know
history that were you from America it
was no Christian country it was a
country belong to South America to to
Native Americans the Europeans not you
the Europeans came and murdered and
killed raped genocide the original
Americans for the sake of Christianity
likewise in Australia likewise in Canada
likewise in Africa the French came to
our country for 132 years and their
forced Christianity they killed us raped
our woman yet
European now left Christianity and the
Muslim countries that European chapter
forced Christianity on them they stay
Muslims that shows you how Islam is
strong
advised point of view it was not bias
historically I'm talking based up on
issue just just one point brother just
just one point good to your point uh on
the rise of uh Islam I've been to a
couple of countries including
Netherlands what's interesting in
Netherlands is there's a national museum
of Netherlands if you go to Amsterdam do
visit that the national museum of
Netherlands has a special section that
says how to convert to Islam
it doesn't say how to convert to
Christian how to convert to you know any
other religion Islam and I was quite
curious I was like why do you have this
section yeah in a country like
Netherlands so there were like a lot of
people come to us we want to convert to
Islam and we don't know how to so that's
why we love this section
and I'm like no why not Christian why
not they say
if there is a demand we will do it but
there is no demand people are coming to
us every day saying I want to convert to
Muslim and I said why is that so why why
do people want to convert to Muslim he's
like I think when because you know in
Netherlands
you could go go to any coffee shop and
ask for drugs
wine drugs whatever so at a point in
time people are depressed and they say
when we look forward to Islam when we
start praying we feel we feel we feel
better that's why a lot of people are
coming there's just just one thing I
noticed yeah
I wanted to bring up that point because
the spirit of Islam
um
a big part of that is
it's due to fatality rates um that's not
true that's a lie that's not that is a
pure lie that is by what's his name used
to come here what's the name whose name
is
the American guy the liar the biggest
liar this is named American white guy
used to come
is alive because we're in Britain that
is the biggest lie about birth rate in
America in Britain
yeah even globally globally I'm not
talking about globally I'm talking about
Europe focus in Europe yeah in Europe
or in France France as you know France
France the biggest hypocrites France
Deja was crazy in our country in Algeria
and Morocco Tunisia with LA liberte
Freedom come to France there's a freedom
there is no Freedom it's a lie European
and the Western World they're not a life
of Freedom there's no Freedom it's a lie
just to deceive the people anyway French
the bandwat hijab
the advantage as you know you know you
know when uh girls they're not allowed
to a hijab yeah under 18. but look at
the hypocrisy I just want to show you
something the Western world is going
crazy about Afghanistan not allowing a
woman to come to go to to go to schools
or colleges as they claim I'm not sure
I've investigated it but yet they have
they haven't not said nothing against
the French who are they not allow you
know girls to go study because they
choose to wear head scarf or hijab and
so on anywhere in France they bent hijab
they found a majority of people of women
women that were hijab
are rivers
they don't even have parents to force
them so the French they say no no one
has forced me to wear it but we're
telling you you've been forced to just
as European when they come to Africa
even whenever called them to come to
Africa they say no you're backward we're
saying we're not backward no we're okay
said no you're backward and we're going
to rape your woman and torture you and
kill you to show you backward that's
European mentality my point here is
majority of rivers Islam is
inclining increasing because of reverse
and you see me outside the station every
Friday I'm dead last week one person
became Muslim the week before one one
six I see with my own eyes around the
world there's a Brothers in the DC in
Washington there's a Brothers in
Germantown Philly there is a promise and
you can see that with your own eyes you
cannot deny it people will shouting
Jesus the same numbers even probably
even more in America but come on
mentioned
respect to get people more than Jesus
man
lgbtq more respected Jesus
that's my points in Europe
a Christian country yes Christianity
[Music]
um you were talking about the research
being false it's
dot or something but anyway let's move
on because you talked about like people
uh raping women and in the name of
Christianity Etc yeah that happened with
Islam as well the sahabas did that when
they when they took over all the Jewish
and Christian towns moving moving uh
Western to show me show me
it's a town in villages they burn
churches this is alive because clearly
now the Islamic teachers I'm going to
show you what the Christians did they
were implementing the Bible Prophet
Muhammad told us in the Quran mentioned
that as well we're not allowed to burn
people place of worship Prophet Muhammad
said when you go to the world do not
kill a woman do not kill children do not
kill a man in his Temple do not ban that
bend down buildings or trees so if
someone did something against Islam
however Christians they are implementing
the teaching of the Bible because the
Old Testament teaches you that when you
go to the town you should kill man and
woman and children and babies you
understand so the first the first ship
the first boat the Old Testament yeah
but the first the first boat the first
boat that departed from America what was
the name of the boat that the first ship
that depart from America to go to Africa
is their people was called Jesus
do research in the name of Jesus not in
the name of Allah because I will be
Allah against Allah you know slavery
that happened in Christianity and and
what you did to Africans you know that
in Islam is forbidden Prophet Muhammad
said anyone that goes around and kidnap
people and take them as the slaves his
prayer will not be accepted
look again you see what I'm saying
I'm only getting seven to the Islam by
the way
the Arab slave trade okay
ever ah please okay okay
understand now there's no verse it says
people that's not there at all but in
the Bible says when you got it tells you
to enslave people
[Music]
Old Testament
do you accept the Old Testament or not
it depends are you trying to go
[Music]
no my point here is sorry so when God
said when God said to go enslaved people
is that good or bad
the question is bad so God tells you to
do something bad
no no you just said that how can I show
you I'll show you where it says go and
take them as slaves
[Music]
ah sorry
all right
what can someone hear this
God
I think that is the astronomy you're
true no
so the Kayla didn't
um
women
[Music]
20 okay let us go to 20 yeah if someone
can get it by someone's picture someone
go to deutsunami 2020 I think
20. do you have the Bible here
the autonomy 2020.
the law of war is
that the war the law of war in God
telling Moses when you go besieged a
town then why do you kill a man and you
keep a woman as well as a property for
yourselves and your offspring
thank you
anyway the plant here is you can look
for it but the point here is what we're
going to tell you here I'm just showing
you
that to go back to the main point that
firstly I'm only getting seven Shoes by
the way also I'm not defending every
Arab here Islam okay because Arab and
the Muslims they make mistakes but what
Islam teaches you understand that's why
if you're going to tell me some Arab did
something I'm not gonna say tell no they
didn't do something
said the Europeans that were Chris that
claim to be Christian did this because
the Bible teaches you do that no the
Bible okay
did the same thing no it was never never
he advised the Muslims when they go to
Sham and Persia likewise they don't kill
children do not kill woman is a clear
cut you understand so don't let
them they did not kill them the men and
take the women as as sex slaves no
there's no something called sex slave
that's in your book sex slaves
whoa six days why
okay if you have a woman if you know is
that better word no no then wives we're
not we're not ashamed to say that out of
the right hand possessed okay yes yes
because why several children Islam only
in a time of War
you know in a time of war the time of
War so Islam came let me explain to you
several children Islam but and as
compared between the Bible and Islam
Islam came before came and slavery or
savior's everywhere everybody was
enslaving everybody you okay you want to
die you're too cold man
oh it's hot there yeah okay that's right
anyway what we say to you so everybody
was in Saving everybody slavery was
based upon death you put on me money
money I cannot give it back to you so
you enslave me until I give you the
money back all people used to kidnap
people Islam came in to show which
Savage is the correct one which one is
only in a time of War because we believe
a man has created the free person as
Adam you know would create free how well
uh Eve subscribe free so servitude was
happening after occurred after so Islam
came in in the time of War Allah gave to
the Muslim leaders four options
or you exchange them with other
prisoners
or you ask for money
or your kid as a servant to serve you
not if your kid as a servant you clothe
them the same garments you will you take
care of them now you kill as a servant
so the Muslim leader has to look at what
is the best interest for the Muslim
Community is it to let them go free to
exchange the prisoners to kill him as a
servant if your kid as a servant as I
have mentioned you take care of them and
there's many ways to let them go free
one of them
the servants come to you say listen I
want to go free let me give you some
money you say okay I agree give me this
amount of money it's upon the Muslim
Community to help the servants to free
himself
subhanallah you hoping also historically
speaking there are many seven Scholars
and the leaders in war
you see they were not treated like worse
than animals you understand in the Bible
teaches you if you have a servant and
it's very disobedient you get him you
put him on the wall you get a nail and
you put it and you smack him with a no
to know that he will stay forever I'll
show you don't move your head with me
you know
I may show you you see so don't you ever
try to compare this slavery in the Bible
or just authentic slavery to the seven
children Islam which is based upon
wisdom and Justice and mighty and mercy
let me show you I'm going to show you I
know you're gonna be surprised it's in
the Old Testament by the way but still
okay
[Music]
Cherry Picked verses that's like me
cherry picking no problem I'm gonna tell
you to read it you tell us what is the
context I mean it's like someone
stabbing someone what is the context I
don't like him the context is not going
to help you you don't like him it's
Injustice
okay
punish your
finger
[Music]
where is it no this one there's one
which which says that you have to
there's one
watch this one just watch this one yeah
anyone who beats the male or female
slave with the road must be punished
yeah so the owner must be punished if
the slave dies but if the slave they are
not if they don't die they are not be
punished if the slave recover since the
slave they are their property so imagine
you have slave and you beat him badly
but he doesn't die you're okay because
he's your property if it dies you got
punished
is that just to beat a man badly you
torture him and you know you know I'm
gonna touch you with a fire I'm gonna
Bend you everywhere because I know the
law in the Old Testament is not going to
punish me as long I don't kill you is
that just I'm asking you is it just a
torture a slave and punish him badly and
nothing happened to you
that's in your Bible read it and I can
get you the context as well
yeah
[Music]
isn't there
let's read more
uh yeah Exodus Exodus
21 20
so page 21 and the passage 2021 yeah a
man Prophet Muhammad he saw a man he was
about to hit his servant prophetam said
yeah Abdullah remember Allah is greater
than you then you're greater than him he
looked he said oh message of Allah and
let him go free he didn't even touch him
he said don't do that then the man he
felt shy he said oh I'll message you
Allah I'll let him go free compare the
prophet's Mercy with this teaching so
how dare you Christian compare Prophet
Muhammad sallam with your God your God
is just
subhanallah I don't believe by the way I
believe that is not God of the Bible I
believe there's many lies against our
god of the Bible because I believe in
Abraham Moses so when I speak like this
I'm not disrespecting the god of Abraham
the god of Moses well I'm showing you
the lies that has been attributed by
scribes through Moses and God of
everything
so you punish someone torture him
humiliate him burn him everywhere as
long as and die you'll be blessed
that's why now we understand why the
Europeans treated the black Africans the
way they treated them
[Music]
but you forget to call friend or 50 50.
I'm joking you're here when you compare
Islam to Christianity or to Quran to the
Bible or teaching Prophet Muhammad you
can see teaching Prophet Muhammad based
upon Mercy wisdom Justice power you know
alhamdulillah the Old Testament but
anyway you haven't asked my question
look at because you said you want to see
the context can you check the context
for me because I don't want to leave
then someone said I'm miscotted so look
at the context please and tell me is it
good that you torture your slave and
nothing happened to you as long we don't
kill him
his lifetime a man came to him his
servant came from his own messenger
Allah
so-and-so tried to cut off my private
parts
companies go get him the man ran away
because he knows the punishment now
of course they are servants but you
treat them
he's so companion sitting down and
someone standing up he said who is this
person he said that's my servant he said
why are you standing let him sit down
with you and eat with you I just read
the context let me read it let me read
it I'll just write the context come on
we've been coming to place for a long
time you know
come let us read the context
[Music]
so there are 21. yeah but you got to
read 20 before you read 21. yeah no
problem Moses said to the people do not
be afraid God has come to test you uh so
that the fear of God will be with you to
keep you from sinning the people remind
us a distance while Moses approached the
thick Darkness where God was
then lord said to Moses tell the
Israelite this you have seen yourselves
that have spoken to you from Heaven do
not make any Gods to be alongside me
and do not make for yourselves God for
of silver or or God of God make an altar
of Earth for me and sacrifice on it you
burn uh you burn you're burnt of
offerings and fellowship okay
who is the contest not the one I'm
talking about
about the pagans
the context is up here who is about the
state
who is the slave one I'm about to tell
you
listen yeah so right here this passage
he's talking to the Lord said to Moses
tell the Israelites and he's talking to
them about the pagans the satanists the
people that worship Baal Satan the
people that worship Satan
well that's not sin that's not yes yes
it is the same no it's not the same look
20 20.
[Music]
320 go go
yeah no no Exodus 20. oh okay so I'll
give you the wrong uh passage no no you
gave me the right passes but you have to
read 20 before you read 21. that's right
look that's 20 21
my contacts is important yeah I read the
context
I mean what's the context you got to
read Exodus 20.
22. start at 2022 and you read that and
then you read 21. so you understand what
he's talking about
so the servants he's addressing are the
Pagan Nations the people that worship
Satan and defile God the god that you
love the god of Abraham yeah so the ones
that get tortured or or get uh the nail
in them are the people that are
satanists so no no no no doesn't say
that no no no make it up man
you just make it up I'm not in the this
is in front of the Bible okay so you
said it's not making it okay if your
servant is a pagan worshiper it's okay
to torture him
yes it depends
um that's why that's why you all went to
church the Africans because you believe
there are pagans
you see you justifying the torture and
the how can you justify this nonsense
you could have been a camera brother I
mean no brother uh what's your name
again
okay X you're gonna be in the camera
justifying the torture of human being
burning him torturing him because he's a
servant yeah but that was that the
Commandments of God
yes at the time so is that something
good to do or something bad
to do to human being
it just depends they're disrespecting
your God right no no no no no no they're
disrespecting your God that's bad so
okay so now if the Muslims go and
torture the Christians it's okay this is
our God it's not because
hypocrisy but it's okay for you to
torture the people
you're not making no sense
this is 21 the the verse you wanted to
cherry pick
these are the laws you are just set
before them who is it them
the pagans the ones that worship idols
and that's where he talks about you know
nail limbs so it wasn't just normal
people it wasn't like a normal person in
the community it was somebody that was
defiling God so they were pagans okay
yes
like I said as a Christian we believe in
the New Testament yeah so we don't have
to go do that anymore Jesus preached
forgiveness
as a Muslim you believe in progressive
revelation right you have prophets that
come it reveals something another
Prophet comes they revealed more and
more and more and the faith makes sense
more time as time go on correct
so at that time yes it was justifiable
to do that to the people that were
defiling God
um but when Jesus came he preached a lot
of people I understand no no by the
points they're bringing you back to if
they're pagans and they violated against
God so why God care about it is going to
die because God says if they die then
you kill the owner
so the good he cares about them if they
die but it's okay to torture them and
punish them this Allah doesn't make any
sense because if God doesn't if God hate
them he does not care about them then if
the owner from the Israelites punished
them and the Pagan dies then that's what
God wants from them because they are
pagans he has he doesn't care about them
but he says if you killed him then the
owner who is the Israelites who God love
he should be killed because of killing
the slave but if he tortures him
humiliates him it's okay what I'm saying
to you this person is a human being a
pagan worshiper or not that's why Islam
comes in with mercy and by the way
Jesus came to him Jesus said Jesus said
in in the talk about Jesus yeah no
problem Jesus said do you suppose that I
came with peace not at all but my points
you again is to make a show make it
clear so you saying win God as you
believe when the Israelites they were
torturing the slaves and punishing them
but because of pagans it was okay to
touch your human being and punish him
and humiliate him
[Music]
people so you justifying torturing
servants and punish him so now remember
we have to remember now
their master and the people in the
family then they get punished not like
they're taking them and they're
punishing right away
regardless even if you do a look look
even if you disobey look look Islam
understand that if you survey they're
discipline yeah but what I'm saying
Islam when you talk about servants those
servants they were pagans too okay
to yourself
it make them eat from the same food you
know look after them in the stand that's
why many servants became Muslims in
Islam that's why there was a Empire
called Empire of the memory League this
mamelic mean the Empire of the servants
that was in Egypt the actual servant
became a leader Kings they will rule
over the Muslim world in the stand so
when you see how Islam legislate how to
treat the prisoners who want the options
you can kill as a servant how they
become Muslims and you compare between
you driving us crazy with God's
all-loving he loves everything and
everyone yet he's allowing human being
to be tortured and humiliated and
punished again
how many times
so before Islam came with the mercy and
stuff Jesus was the one that was pushed
not for 600 years before so that
commandment was Egypt from Jesus or not
in the Old Testament
so Jesus and we believe in Progressive
no problem Jesus no no no wait Jesus no
no no EG is all love it all the times is
Jesus all loving all the time of course
it's all the time so when he was saying
when Jesus was telling the Israelites to
torture and punish and humiliate human
being without all of him no no no no no
no ask him a question you have children
no no before I have children no he said
she's all loving he loves everyone yes
so when he was saying to the Israelites
to torture a slave and humiliate him and
punish him with that or love him
yes we take care of yourself
so I'm gonna kill you and punish you if
you tell me why something because I'm
loving you man
so have you had a handful of Islam
children you're gonna
torture them no one do that how are you
gonna torture your child I'm gonna
discipline my child that's what prophet
Muhammad said again I'll take you to the
best example ever existed Muhammad he
said when you want to discipline your
child when you do avoid the face
I don't leave no Mark you don't beat him
up like Mike Tyson you're not fighting
understand so compare looks the mercy of
Muhammad you know when you say Islam
they will eat the foundation makes sense
the branches make sense that's why you
see Islam spreading as a relation that
go in line with our sound reasoning and
natural information that's why human
beings naturally gravitate towards Islam
observation and what I've been doing for
the last 15 years speaking to
non-muslims and I see how they gravitate
towards Islam just by explaining Islam
to them we're just here in London you
need to travel more I travel more I went
to Ireland I went to Scotland
no our brothers America in Germantown in
German you know Philly in German Town
there's a measure called Somali the
German Town literally every Saturday
I'll probably see that were there
somewhere except Islam in Ramadan 55
people except Islam
those Christian events are doing the
same numbers
come on man
serious
out of not bias well I have respect you
you have to understand yeah you got to
understand that you have to smell your
coffee to wake up whenever any coffee
because you have to wake up you got to
read the Bible with contest because that
Exodus passage you
the the punishment of a human being
because he's a pagan that's a context
correct because it was a pagan
there's more Concepts what was more
context it was a pagan disobeying
um the Masters children and the wives
you got to read the whole Concepts it
doesn't say this is doesn't say
disrespects
there is it when he said this is back
doesn't say read it read it okay but if
the servants declare I love my master
and my and my wife and children and do
not want to go free then his master must
take him before oh no no watch this one
thank you very much this worst one this
is not the one yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch this one yeah
brothers and sisters you know thank you
very much
good for you man you see a nice guy you
know you seem a nice guy yeah don't
record him just blur him if you record
him I have respect you know no no listen
to this
but if the servant declares I love my
master and my wife not the Master's wife
his wife and children and don't want to
go free he doesn't want to go free then
okay this servant does not go free then
his master must take him before the
judges he shall take him to the door of
the doorpost and Pierce his air with an
owl then he will be his servant for life
all right can you can you Google what is
Owl am I pronounce it correctly
awl
yeah
gossip images go images go images yeah
go images
screwdriver
screwdriver so it is seven doesn't want
to go free he said to his master I don't
want to go free so he should the master
no tap okay don't go free that's good
because you love your wife you love me
I'm gonna take care of you no you get
him and you put this on his air like
screwdriver and Pierce him
you give us another another proof that
this is this judgment
s
you just gave me another proof of my
statements
may Allah help you man but lie
you see my nice guy I pray to Allah
guide you to truth well I pray you see
my nice guy don't record it
doesn't want to be recorded you know
yeah
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no
it's not about that why is he about you
go home watch inshallah reflect upon it
and pray it's not about who's winning
here me I'm an Algerian Moroccan of
Africa we speak like this where we speak
we speak with passion you know but we
love
goodness where are you from originally
maybe you're working actually originally
serious
anyway Mala guy do you know and I'm I
apologize if I was speaking rude to you
and Cat and you but what I'd like to do
to establish the truth clearly and
simply for people to understand that's
why I like you know he's not shouting
that's how it is
foreign